all right let's cover a couple of other
things um it is in an increasingly
difficult job for the lawyers that have
been hired and I use the term hired
Loosely because it's never really clear
that they're getting paid the lawyers
that have been hired by Donald Trump to
defend him and to make the arguments in
the court of public opinion or in the
media that will really sway anybody now
I've already said to you before
the arguments they make on TV they often
will not make an accord of Law and we
saw that over the last couple of days
but sometimes it gets to the point where
they don't even really have arguments
that they can make on TV and one of
Donald Trump's lawyers Alina Haba
appeared yesterday on Newsmax and all
sorts of other media outlets and nothing
that she said was particularly
persuasive one of the claims she tried
to make in this first clip is that the
reason Trump's buildings are worth so
much more than many will acknowledge
is because of the intangible
value-raising name recognition that
calling a building a Trump building has
now unfortunately this isn't true but
here's Elena Haba trying to make this
argument number one number two when you
have a trump property that's a unicorn
property that's what we call that that's
something that has a brand that's what
we in the business call them the value
and has Real Estate Value he's got some
of the best buildings in New York so you
want to sit there and tell me oh Trump
do you know what a property's worth it's
worth what someone's willing to pay for
it it doesn't matter what Leticia James
thinks now the only problem with this
argument is that Trump's properties
increasingly seem beleaguered by being
called Trump whatever in fact remember
some of these stories from when was this
from last year Trump branded New York
building looks to remove president's
name ex president's name on Tower
reduces its value this is the opposite
of the argument that Elena Haba is
making other examples Business Insider
from 2019 all the places that have
removed Trump's name since he won in
2016. and there's this whole list of
places
um to ice skating rinks removed Trump
signs nine other buildings removed Trump
signs so it's just a lie in fact not
only might the Trump name not increase
value it might diminish value here is
um another one of these clips where it
she it just doesn't sound very
convincing we'll be ready to grow and we
will continue to crush it we're going to
continue to crush it it is what it is
it's an election political Ploy here we
go Leticia you know you made a mistake
you wanted to file but it's going to be
another l in your bucket here we go yeah
I'm not finding her supercro edible nor
super persuasive here is
um the same lawyer Alina Haba on a
different show on I guess this is also
Newsmax this one's called Rob Schmidt
tonight and again I'm not finding her
arguments particularly I really think
persuasive is the right the right word
now the Department of Justice filed this
crazy raid pretending it's all these
criminal actions because it's around the
corner to November and this is what we
like to call an October surprise which
we've seen before yeah so it's an
October surprise
in September before a November in which
Donald Trump is not actually running
hmm it's not making a lot of sense Alina
and of course one of the realities that
eventually we just start to bump up
against is
you can't always defend the indefensible
you just can't you get to a certain
point where okay listen you know what I
don't know I don't know between the
Mar-A-Lago thing and the Georgia thing
and the January 6th thing and the New
York fraud thing and all of the other
things and the alleged rape thing and
all these at some point you just can't
keep continue you can't continue
defending the indefensible and that's
what Trump's lawyers are now up against
and it's quite a pleasure to see I have
to tell you hopefully they're at least
getting paid which is a really tough
thing to collect when you are working
for Donald Trump